j'ai reçu à peu près 40 mille j'ai
arrêté de compter menaces de mort de
viol appel au suicide ou à tuer toute ma
famille et autres insultes
[Musique]
j'ai fait une vidéo en 2016 sur le
harcèlement de ruer sur la drague de rue
et sur la manière qu'on a en france en
général de blâmer les victimes toujours
en trouvant des excuses aux agresseurs
est dedans j'en ai profité pour dire aux
personnes qui draguait dans la rue que
c'était assez malvenu puisque la plupart
des filles que je connais voir toutes
les filles que je connais dans la rue se
sentent pas en sécurité s'habille en
faisant attention à pas être comme ci ou
comme ça font en sorte de rentrer en
taxi le soir parce qu'elles ont peur de
prendre le métro
donc j'essaye de dire aux personnes qui
drape dans la rue même avec toute la
bienveillance du monde et avec les
meilleures intentions que
potentiellement ça peut être mal pris et
que la rue n'est pas un lieu où on
drague et ça a mis beaucoup beaucoup en
colère une grosse partie des internautes
qui a décidé de de ne pas débattre avec
moi mais devenir m'insulter et me
menacer de mort de viol faire des appels
au suicide ou venir me glisser des mots
dans ma boîte aux lettres
on a toujours minimisé ce que disent les
femmes
est ce que vivent les femmes donc il ya
un certain nombre de femmes qui ont dit
moi je dis ça sur internet et on leur a
dit ouais mais ça doit être de ta faute
potentiellement tu as dis un truc qu'il
fallait pas tout à fait ce 6 août a fait
cela et puis tu ta fiche et puis en fait
tu l'a un peu cherché la loi n'est pas
faite pour aider les gens qui se
considèrent harceler la loi n'est déjà
pas fait pour aider les femmes qui se
font harceler dans la rue donc forcément
sur internet c'est déjà encore plus
difficile de faire valoir ce qui nous
est arrivé sur internet au delà de
l'anonymat on a un effet de d'impunité
c'est à dire que on voit le voisin
insulter quelqu'un et il n'est pas puni
il n'est pas poursuivi et personne lui
tape sur les doigts personne lui dit que
c'est mal il a jamais entendu que
c'était mal nulle part donc forcément si
on voit des gens dans notre entourage
faire ça on se dit que c'est faisable et
que c'est pas très grave et si ça peut
nous soulager de manière immédiate un
petit peu comme une branlette
on va le faire on a tous une voie et on
peut tous utilisés à bon escient
si on est capable d'accepter que des
insultes puisse détruire quelqu'un on
est capable d'accepter que des
compliments et du soutien puisse
construire quelqu'un tu es là tu regarde
derrière ton écran soit soit actif
commentent les cinq heures mais un pouce
en haut ça sert se sera vu et ce sera
remercié si j'ai un conseil à donner à
toutes les personnes qui se font
emmerder en ligne qui se font harceler
en ligne pour des raisons de genre de
couleurs de sexualité ou de quoi que ce
soit continuer à faire exactement
exactement ce que vous voulez parce que
c'est que en jouissance votre liberté
qu'un jour vous serez vraiment libre
c'est qu'en montrant l'exemple de ce que
c'est qu'être libre qu'un jour vous
pourrez plus jamais touché par des
personnes qui vous interdise de l'être
les femmes se serre les coudes de plus
en plus les femmes sont toutes ensemble
les femmes sont unis et les femmes sont
en train de se rendre compte de la force
qu'elles ont c'est à dire qu'on a
beaucoup été écrasée réduite au silence
et à la honte et on est en train de ne
plus avoir de tolérance vis-à-vis de ça
donc internet est en train de permettre
un mouvement dans lequel je le vois avec
beaucoup d'espoir les femmes vous
on réussir à sortir de leur condition et
à dire mais en fait je je suis forte et
je t'emmerde